the Joe Rogan experience take I think
after December 12th YouTube's gonna be
able to if your channels not
commercially viable they'll be able to
just get rid of it if they want that is
a that's a way for them to stop
something in his tracks
okay that's what I think so say if some
new guy comes along like you you come
along spitting fire talking [ __ ] and
everybody's getting fired up and oh my
god look what he said about Meghan
McCain I mean Meghan McCain calls up
YouTube you listen we're gonna take the
view we're gonna pull it off of YouTube
yeah get rid of that [ __ ] fat [ __ ]
that's yeah fascinating me that is this
I sometimes I wonder
yeah if like the shadow banning stuff is
cuz I just made Gary Vaynerchuk mad and
I'm like I don't you know I made a joke
about him do you think he's powerful
enough to just go to all these companies
and be like maybe I don't know right I
don't think you would do that I'm
kidding I love you I I'm inspired by you
every day it's all a bit it's a bit
solid joke I think it's great when you
happen with him well I mean I you know I
have a joke about him I really you know
have a joke I made a little video about
him because some of the things he tweets
he tweets a kindness is delicious come
on what are we doing he puts out a
little too much context also like all my
loser friends think you're gonna be the
CEOs of companies because this guy is
telling them there's a business inside
of everyone and there's not there's just
not a business inside of every but
there's a lot of people that you
shouldn't be like you know they should
just fall in line fall in line we don't
need everyone thinking that they're
gonna be the next Slayer he's got to
send the message out there as if
everyone can be that way the people that
are listening and get it the people that
get like they're like okay he's saying
everyone can that means me I'm gonna go
for it and then they make it and I
appreciate him doing that but I need to
send the message that most people can't
a lot of people show in the same way
that he has a message I have a message
my message is you're not it's not gonna
happen and he has the but it's also
there's no specific guidance with a lot
of these guys not only him but he'll say
things like you could talk about it or
you could do it but you better do both
and it's like well what's the in like he
tweeted once because ideas are [ __ ] it's
all about execution it's like execute
what what are we gonna do I need help
my kids are sick
execute what can you text me do I meet
you somewhere how do we start this how
do we build these businesses are we
gonna do it together why do you think he
got mad he got mad I'm just kidding I
don't know if he's mad or not I wonder
if a guy like that has a sense of humor
I'm a Keynesian then you get pulled that
you did my my did garyvee thing they
took it off YouTube no I mean they took
it off Instagram IG no right then he
walked in a room with a bunch of guys in
little hoodies and he was like get this
fatty and they did that because I
respect power respect power Gary I get
it I'm just saying I'm a funny guy me
and you we'll do a podcast Gary it's
fine he's a small I respect him I
respect him he's a smart guy right he's
smart he's I just I wonder how many
successful people need that like just
Warren Buffett like look at his phone
ago it's time to hustle how do you know
get a parody of you removed from
Instagram probably didn't I'm just a
consider a tube still yeah let's play it
where is it that's probably on YouTube
when I want to hear what you said and I
want to see what was the trigger well it
was also waived the knife around stuff
that should've done it my whole point
was it when you make these when you give
people very general and vague I need to
see this now I need a smoke this general
and vague advice what sometimes happens
is that you know you know people can you
like David hog tweeted the other day he
goes it's the hardest days in our lives
that makes us who we are
so then I sub tweeted it and I wrote
okay so no gun control right I mean and
my point there is not to say anything
shitty about hog but to say listen if
you're just gonna tweet vague
meaningless horse [ __ ] all day like
that's well that kid does David Holloway
company because racism is bad and it cuz
42,000 likes it's like country's [ __ ]
out well isn't he like 17
he's a child we got to stop listening to
children yeah well that was Louie's joke
yes out parkland survivors he's back
he's bad he's killing my [ __ ] friends
so I showed you that he's like it's the
best hour it's amazing I heard he
murdered a guys did amazing of them
guy did a review of him he said I have a
very complicated relationship with Luis
okay I think what he did was horrible I
was a fan of his I was greatly
disappointed but then I saw his new set
and was [ __ ] amazing yes yes no one
even knows what he did he's like I think
what he did was horrible it's like
describe what he did the guy's like ha
well I you know did you see that girl
that oh here I found you found okay play
this nice way too by the way oh it's on
Twitter sweat hey buck by the way stop
pausing for a second shout out to
Twitter shout out to Twitter Thank You
Twitter they let it fly quitter let
megan mccain fly they let it all flow
twitter lets everything fly that you
could take it in the ass on twitter
their porn it's an adult website this is
for adults I just love that they do that
they kept the Megan McCain thing up
whereas YouTube or Instagram took it
down Instagram yeah two things taken
down well maybe it was strikes buddy
that's why I'm not I'd merely put the
videos on Twitter on you on the
Instagram anymore cuz I don't wanna lose
my account good call let's hear it let's
hear this I learned the most important
world ever crying and just keep hustling
guys we're building businesses here
where do I need you man I can do it and
so you can say it or you can do it but I
highly recommend you do both I'll do it
I'll say it and I'll do it I used to
work in a liquor store for 73 years and
the only days off I took work to watch
the New York Jets and you know what that
did it made me throw up on myself so
that was a vacation sick nobody gives a
[ __ ] about your problems what about the
word jug I should kill the president
stupid
maybe it's like 3:00 a.m. tomorrow it's
[ __ ] hilarious Gary you know median
it's a commit we just gotta have a
little fun Gary we love you we love you
Gary graduations on all your success
[Applause]